i think we are live so uh
welcome everybody i'm thrilled to be
here
with my dear friend shelly and gary and
so i bet everybody's asking about
why are we here why is capitalize
on you so important um i believe money
is power
and i've always said that i've said that
to both of you
um but unfortunately women abdicate
control of the pocketbook um and that's
time to change
my personal mission is on equality and
equality across
race gender age ability
and capital is a factor and so if we're
going to change it and we're going to
reach equality
we've got to reach it by educating
on how you can capitalize on you so
i i thought we were here to create one
of the most successful podcasts
in the history of podcasts i might i
might have gotten the wrong invite i
mean
all those things are marvelous and true
i just wanted to make sure i was in the
right
live stream and the right podcast like
like can i still stay here because that
is a huge agenda of mine
the single most impactful podcast in the
history of podcasts well gary and i was
going to jump in
and say because this is a big problem
because there's two taboo words for
women
money and power so am i on the right
show because here i am the chick and why
don't we see women on the dollar bill
on the one the ten to twenty let's go to
a hundred i mean what is wrong with this
picture so hope
thanks for setting the context actually
real quick just to like completely
take that with this show because i'm
really excited about this and everybody
i'm gary vaynerchuk i'm unbelievably
humbled
to be with these and two incredible
women talking about something i think
needs a lot more attention actually for
pure fun
because i think what is great about this
show is we are going to go deep and for
everybody's listening like
this is really going to get into value
land and
i kind of i'm excited about this being
more steak than sizzle
but real quick just for super fun shelly
i'll start with you and hope i'll give
you the extra few seconds to think
who would you put on which dollar like
if we were like fully in charge we got a
weird email
you three are in charge of putting the
first woman on
american currency shelly who would you
put on
and on which bill okay well so
thank you for asking that question
because we actually
worked with this the treasury the
secretary of treasury on putting a woman
on the bill in the obama administration
and it was going to be harriet tubman on
the front of the ten
and why the 10 the 10 because the 10
will be re-created
for the 100 year anniversary of women's
right to vote so it was a monumental
moment for women to put
her on the front of the 10. the problem
was hamilton is on the front of the 10.
so we were going to be relegated to the
back of the bill
and so i don't believe we belong in
little jpegs on the back we belong on
the front
and a guy can move over for a little
while for us to take
the front we were going to be pushed to
the 20.
the 20 is the bill that is an atm
machine so it's the most popular bill
but i think now that has been delayed
once again with this administration so
harriet
okay so i'm gonna start from a totally
different angle i wrote my college essay
about queen elizabeth the first as this
absolute you know woman
leader we don't have that we haven't had
that and let's just hope
we do soon um and so
i would have actually always gone for
the the woman queen
um we don't have that but i'm also on
the other side of my
life is fighting for the unsungs all the
women you don't know
i joke and i say about the women of
hidden figures
they did the they did the work before
the movie came out
okay those are people that i also want
on
every bill um and we've got to get women
into the role
of power into the monetary role of power
and recognition
but so i would start them i i start them
on the one
um because that's the bill that's used
the most
it i think it's going out of style i
think currency by the way is going out
of style we can have another
conversation about
that we have a lot of episodes to get
into that exactly but
gary was thinking about it as you were
talking i was like are we going to move
to the next thing or
or one of two of you gonna ask you know
i
i think in a lot of different like rosa
parks was the name i was thinking a lot
about because i
because it kind of mixes the two answers
you guys gave and that's where i think i
play a little bit
meaning i i i like where you went hope
because i think
in general i'm very similar like i think
a lot about my life and like why do i
do operations i have all this leverage
i'm in the prime of my career
and like the silliest thing i actually
do is
actually run the business that i run
from the standpoint of
there's a lot of other people that are
incredible at operations
and what i you know was luckily in the
dna game given
that's a harder rarer trait but i just
enjoyed the operations part
it's the un it's the unsung part of me
that i've operated businesses it's why i
wanted to do this when i was talking to
you two
because i think this show's going to
deal with a lot of practicality and i
think practicality
is very underrated and i think what rosa
parks did
was just a very practical real-life
thing she wasn't
a queen which is amazing and and
obviously that was a very progressive
queen
she was just a normal human being living
her life and was just at a place where
like hey i don't think this makes sense
which very speaks to my heart
because basically i just navigate life
trying to figure out what
does and doesn't make sense to me and
it's and it
bodes well so i think you know the five
dollar
bill five is my favorite number that's
why i always put up the photo with my
hand like this since i take so many
selfies
five is the number of the on the jet
jersey that my mom sewed to me so i
would put on the five dollar bill and i
would go with rosa parks because i think
a very simple act that i'm sure was done
many many other times
by people that were suppressed during
that time that was the right moment
that caught the consciousness and and
and
and here we are just think about the
nature of it
a regular human being did something
again
that i think happened many other i don't
think she was the first
black woman or black male that said i'm
not moving
it's just the one it's the one that's
sad
and i i like that it speaks to my
underdog nature
it definitely speaks to what i think
hope is very right on which is
there's an ungodly amount of people
doing it today and
so that's where i would go with rosa
parks on the five but you know it's
interesting when you talk about
how much you love the operational side
because you're not someone that sits
still
for very long and you are very
non-operational
you're always creating your own rules
which is why i think you also love
rosa parks because she was a
non-confused yeah
and and i'm pr i'm practical
after you break the system and i think
that's a very
that's a really nice segue to what i
think we're doing here and i'll let hope
continue to take the lead you know my
my you know obviously you know i'm the
guy
host on here but like for me what what
is what is so powerful
is practicality is underrated
and i think on this subject matter the
practice this is what has
always attracted me to hope's message
around this through the last decade
is the practicality of the relationship
of money
and women is fascinating to me and
sits in that place of like what's
happening in the subconscious this is
why i love branding
right we talk about subconscious bias
and the political things but i think
about subconscious decision making
it's what i do well in marketing and i
think like
what i hope this is is a seed my great
dream of this
is that there's somebody that's
listening to this maybe the third
episode
you know and she or he for that matter
is just driving along or running on a
treadmill and this
this series becomes the seed to that
person's life work
and that person becomes the person that
operationalizes a massive change
and by the way my hope is that there's
13 people not just one
so you know for me you're right i
only look to break systems but then but
what makes me not a pontificator
or somebody that just lives on linkedin
cursing or even
more noble versions of it a politician
or a teacher or an author what makes me
none of those things
is my deep obsession with then
operating my hyperbole and thesis like
making it real life
uh not just something i yell about over
a bourbon
so that's kind of like that's i'm very
excited about this endeavor i'm so
honored to be on this with you too
well gary the whole thing is you walk
the walk you always have
you actually will go after me hard i'll
go after you hard
i'm i like to say about my personal
career
i never thought of myself as a girl okay
i thought
i thought of myself as just one of the
guys and as
a human exactly and i think that that's
the key
and that's the grid and all this
conversation about
money and success everybody thinks that
it has to be so
formulaic and learned here in this
calculus class
it's not right gary and shelly
like your pathway to your financial
success
gary i know you'd personally joke about
how well you did academically
yeah right i mean
it wasn't your math grades right
listen i got a d in statistics and i
went on to build the largest
fastest growing research company in the
world so it ain't in a textbook that's
all i want to say and that's where
motto amano i mean we completely go
together i think it's about experiences
that trigger
you know the the success i hire for
passion train for spill so i've always
followed
my passion and the money has followed
versus
going after this job because i'm
supposed to
that just never felt right to me i think
i think one quick thing to set up this
show from day one this series
you know what i'm very aware of is that
an
outrageous amount of men are going to
listen to this i think we are going to
come through the filter and the
perspective and the angle
of women's relationship with money
because i think it's a very very very
big gap
but i'll be very frank because i like to
be i was actually
i i'm like excited to listen to hope and
some of the guests too because like
i it you know i'm an incredible earner
when it comes to business like i know
how to make dollars but
making your money work for you is an
absolute skill set and i think that
they'll we'll be touching on some of
that so some of the people that are
listening especially
i'm just going to make some assumptions
from my audience land i think this is
going to bring some really
financial education that i would argue
anybody can make and really the theme
for me in life
let alone this show is what hope said
earlier which is i don't think of myself
as a guy either i think of myself as a
human which is
what deploys so much of my empathy i'm
struggling to see my difference
between me and everybody else i still
think i'm 18 when i talk to 18 year olds
and i think i'm 81 when i talk to 81
year olds
boy girl black brown or indifferent or
white so i'm excited about this show
keep setting up the context hope because
we have an incredible guest and uh and
the three of us can blab into like left
field for the rest of the show and kind
of
not nail what we want to do here so gary
it's about
how to make money how to how to
capitalize in your career
and multiply that money how to build
your equity
and i really want to say there are the
water cooler moments on advice
on investments and during covid you've
done a great job in marketing for the
now and shel you've done
all these great programs but we've got
to build these water cooler moments
and help you get that advice and that's
one of the reasons i wanted
i think doing this now is so
fundamentally important
because it is we none of us in this
screen
look at each other as anything else but
people who want to move the needle
forward
for all and in a productive
lifelong learning way shelly what's your
two cents on what made you sign up for
this or what you're excited about this
or how you see this
playing out well i think a lot of it is
you know for me in business i never
um really was given my value
or told you know you are going to be a
rock star and very
successful i had to make my bed i had to
find my way
create my path learn how to negotiate
for myself
believe in me because no one else did so
i think um you know it's it's lessons i
think the best advice comes from people
who have been there done that
and don't have the perfect um textbook
example of what making money growing
money
um and and gaining power and what
kind of responsibility you have with
that power um to help the others
you know rise the rank so for me as a
woman in business
it is very important for women to
understand that it's not just about
money and power as we talked about but
the capitalize on you
how do you capitalize on yourself um to
continue
to grow and also love what you do
because i think that that is part of
success and and money
it's great yeah i think it's bringing it
all together i think it's bringing it
all together
so that we can make a difference that we
can lift everybody up we talk about that
we all
three of us talk about that um and
now is the time and hopefully the world
will be a better place
if we can accomplish it one quick thing
for everybody listening
post this recording we do have a live
audience watching on facebook i
am basically incapable of not reading
the comments
while i'm doing a show so i just want to
do a fair warning that i'll probably be
doing
some interrupting and random comments
for people that won't have
any sense of it for example i'm
demanding that my team
here bans clasher in the comments who
continues to put
go bills i am very salty of the day of
this recording the monday after the jets
opening game
so uh i'm kidding do not ban clasher but
uh we will uh
what i will try to do since i have a
little practice in this we have
incredible guests i think we're aiming
for two we want to do the first episode
with only one just because we wanted to
set the tone but
the series will have two guests um
per episode is kind of our ambition i'm
correct in that right hook
and then and i will also try to play the
role of interjecting with the
people from uh facebook who are trying
to lives
which is where this is being aired uh
who are maybe adding two cents and maybe
i'll incorporate into some of my
questions
and or for hope or shelly so i will
establish that i'm really excited about
this how many
what did we say we're probably we're
doing this like everything i i do i i
can't speak for the other two ladies
where we're doing a certain amount and
then
we'll take it to where the wind does but
how many are we locked in for four or
six what did we end up doing
i think we're saying six but i mean i
think what's your point gary as well
um we we came up with a name by polling
everybody
we actually want other people what what
do you want as advice as well
we have we have the shows lined up we
believe in being flexible and answering
some of the needs that are out there
because no vote is perfect well i think
that the reason
the three of us came together is
anything goes
i think we we've created our
success in very different ways very
non-linear paths
hopes was a little more linear but very
non-linear and i think that that is the
best advice so we also want people to be
sending in questions
ask us anything and we will you know
give you to the best of our ability you
know real life stories and real life
examples
including the guests that we're bringing
in to share them so i think that that's
what's so important about this
ask us anything and anything goes
guard and and anybody who knows any one
of the three of us
knows that we will ask each other tough
questions
and we will answer them authentically
because
that's what that's what matters that's
what helps the discussion
and again going back to my view on women
and girls and
and money they didn't they didn't ask
they didn't ask the question
and because they're afraid and we got to
stop
that there's no such thing as a bad
question
well i think i'm gonna stop that fear
you gave
great advice when i said you know there
is
a whole concept of best advice for how
to
invest your money um pre-cover days and
then you said and what people aren't
thinking about
is the different strategies during covet
and so i would love to hear from you
we're just waiting for mindy to join
while we're waiting give us some great
financial advice for how to
invest differently during this coving
moment
well i mean listen the first thing i i
put up a couple of pieces
on linkedin i think it's really
important
is you got to first count your bananas
and and i mean that and gary and i
talked about that
because it actually came from gary gary
knew what every cost in his office was
every single company i've ever invested
in that's what we did
first what what do you have because
before you can talk about investing
shelly
what do you have what are your upcoming
expenses and this is not calculus right
this is
a plus b right what do you minus c what
do you have
and then you can decide how to invest
because then what do you need when do
you need that money
right might you need that money because
if you need that money
tying it up in a longer term strategy
will is is not a good idea so it's about
your liquidity
and it's about your tolerance for risk
so i think the answer is there isn't one
answer shelley it's
actually is individual but but first
assess what you have assess what you
need
and assess whether you're not going to
need when you need to access that money
anytime in the near future right private
investments that can yield you a lot of
money
are highly risky sometimes yeah let's
talk about that for a hundredth of a
second
like highly risky like high like
like everyone you know what happens we
have these moments of time
when people become fascinated about
things
and startup investing everybody like the
older set
couldn't wait to find their son or
daughter's best friend
that was going to be the next mark
zuckerberg like we are a
hollywood storytelling infatuated
society
the social network movie comes out and
literally i mean like i took
thousands of these meetings over the
course of a decade
regular businessmen and women reached
out to me because i come from a regular
business before i got into the silicon
valley stuff
and like the smartest most conservative
guys and gals i knew from the liquor
business mainly guys
would say things like hey i want to put
100k into a startup
do you know any mark zuckerberg like
that i'm like do you understand the math
around facebook like like 98
likelihood 99 likelihood that you're
about to put 100
especially at that time like i would
argue that post this pandemic
if things get tighter like i haven't
really i haven't and hope you know this
i haven't really
invested in startups the last three or
four years and oh by the way the ones i
have i've done extremely well
because it's back to what i did three
like the first time with facebook
facebook tumblr and twitter for me were
i believe in ev williams i believe in
mark zuckerberg i believe in david carp
i believe in the traction they already
have tens of millions of users
not oh this person went to a good
college
seems smart and i subjectively like this
idea with no context do they have the
stomach to be an entrepreneur
and that's what i went back to like i
just had a very large exit with liquid
iv
unilever just bought like i didn't even
want to invest in
in brandon's company i it was just so
obvious to me that this kid was going to
win
right it's what happened with me with
mcmack i keep doubling down on rachel
tipigraph like
like sometimes i just can't help because
it's so obvious to me about the human
but yeah i mean for everybody who's
watching right now
investing like you know like
i i just think that this this is what i
want to get into because i know
what hope and shelley bring to the table
and i think what i'm going to be
watching and doing more listening than
normal is like when can i inject like
now like right now the point is this
no it is not highly risky it is almost
guaranteed that you will lose money if
you invest in a startup
correct that is a big deal because i
think most people think it's like
a 50 50 crap shoot like no no and you
have to put 25 or 50 or 100k in to even
get in
so it's like it's not like buying 10
shares of apple
or like or like buying like what i'm hot
on now a baseball card that might go
down or might go
up you're locked in for 20 to 50k
and you're locked in kind of forever
like it's not liquid
you can't sell it you can't go to the
open market and go sell it you go buy
those 10 shares of apple
and you can sell it if you need the
money you go invest in a startup you
can't you have to assume it's going to
fail
and it's that's a really
i've ever put into a startup i have 100
written off in my head
i don't need it to pay my bills or to
feed my family it is
gone period so venture investing has to
go
in your highest risk cattle category
okay and only when you can absolutely
afford to lose
every ounce of that so that's real
that's really important and gary there's
one other thing you're not at it you're
not saying about what you do about
venture investing
when you invest in a company you also
give yourself
to that company and by that you're
helping
them get to success faster you're
accelerating
the growth and i had to learn hope that
i wasn't
to your point and that's why i did well
early on because i was
but then as i got stretched in i
realized uh and
my financial situation changed you know
because i
started over at 34 and didn't have a lot
of money
like every dollar was like petrified and
even though i wrote it off i
really wanted it to win whereas now
i realized ugh you know in this kind of
like muckery place three years ago four
years ago which is why i changed my
behavior i'm like oh i'm writing like a
100k which means a lot to me i came from
nothing
but it's not enough to make me go do
something
they're not reaching out to me i'm not
running their company and my
to your point my impact on it was far
less than the early stuff
and far less than the last three or four
that i got involved with
with you know for say mcmac i went on
the board you know like and i'm and it's
close to vaynermedia so i can send
rachel clients
and she's like me so i can tutor a
mentor
that's such a great point i have some
level of impact
to to your point 99 don't you're passive
and it's not liquid and it's 99 likely
to go away
but i think you also are talking about
it's not
just your investment you also are taking
the interest
like when you have an interest in the
company and in the people
that's when you unlock your magic it's
not just a passive investment that you
watch self-awareness one of the things
that i
really want to talk about and i'm going
to let you to take over is like
the and of course we're talking
generalizations so like let there be no
confusion
every human is different but when we
think about this show
especially from the female lens you know
i think
one thing i look for a lot is
self-esteem and self-awareness
right and i and i do think that that is
something that
everybody who's listening now needs to
think about to your point
like for me what i realize is oh right
when i see a scrappy kid
it's why i unfairly razz you know ivy
league kids
they're just as likely to win it just it
doesn't speak to my soul the same way
because it's not who i
am to your point shelly i it took me
time to realize ooh this is what i'm
attracted to
you know the internet kids that i was
investing in 2005 and six they were the
underdogs
right 100 they were nerds
it wasn't cool nobody believed now
it's completely in the other chasm which
is why i've lost my spirit for it
so for everybody's listening find what
your spirit is because that's going to
allow you to go deeper
100 100 percent hope that we're going to
bring in right now
i would love to welcome mindy grossman
who is the ceo of ww
hi it was like the perfect clue as gary
was going on garyvee
about the people we believe in and the
people that can
build a business drive a business not
just inherit one but create one
based on passion and power and and money
and all of those things
there is no one better to reflect those
values than you mindy we are so excited
to have you here
thank you and gary i love what you just
said about self-esteem and
self-awareness i always say
particularly to women self-awareness is
your greatest superpower
um and it's just so important and that
belief in yourself
comes from extreme awareness
but mindy where did that extreme
awareness for you was there a pivot
moment was there one of those
heartbeat moments that you had that said
you know because you've
risen the ranks you've won every
accolade of most powerful women on
you know fortune forbes on you know and
everything was there a moment in your
career
that you found that confidence kind of
uh emanated from you you said i got this
and i can do anything
no i think it's been a journey i think
it's been a journey that's really built
um you know i took a risk very early in
my career
you know i was supposed to be a lawyer i
was supposed to get married and at the
last
uh minute in my last semester at college
and i started college at 16
i just decided to change my life and i
moved to new york at 20 in 1977.
broke my engagement decided not to go to
law school instead i'm going to figure
it out
so i always say not taking the risk
would have been riskier so
it definitely gave me the confidence in
a lot of what i did but when i moved to
new york
i had no finances i didn't have you know
parental support um you know they didn't
have
the wherewithal and so it was really
about my taking care of myself and i
would say that the one thing
in the first few years that i didn't do
enough of
was think about security it was
you know spend what you have and then as
i got older
and i really understood the business
skills i said i'm not applying my
business skills
to my personal life and i need to be
as focused as educated and aware
as i am in business in my personal
finances
and that was a big moment for me uh
and then when i got married i'm married
to
a mathematical physicist who is a
financial
expert right but i wasn't going to
abdicate
my intentions my right and my
understanding of where i wanted to go
with finances
so we've been partners in this journey
the whole time and i think one of the
wake-up calls for me is i had a
girlfriend
who very sadly her husband all of a
sudden
died on the racquetball court and she
had no idea where anything was
their finances their what their status
was
and i remember saying that should happen
to no one
you know you should be the owner of what
it
is your goals are and everything else
now that doesn't mean you can't have a
partner
but you need to be as educated
informed you need to make the right
decisions whether they be about an
investment
um or whether they be about what you
want to save versus what you want to
make and hope i was listening
to you as well earlier everything is
individual whether it's the level of
risk
or you know what you're comfortable with
and what your
joint plans are um and so throughout
you know our relationship even to this
day um
we are both very involved in whatever
decisions that we're making together
um and we certainly have our own
individual investment decisions
and the other point you made that i
thought was really
smart is any startup
investment i make i assume i'm going to
get nothing back
now i do it because i believe
in that you might like that you might
win rachel
right you believe in the person
and you will lend your support so you
know
i made the decision to start investing
in some
early stage women founded businesses
and said i can give them you know
capital
but i can also give them support
um and so if it works great and if not
i've done my best to help support the
investment
andy real quick you played at the
highest levels of
business in this in this world
do you think that financial literacy
because the story you told about the
racquetball
uh gentlemen which is devastating is
such a
common story for the women of the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s
you know and and i think there has been
a turn thank god
but but as you were talking literally i
was like
how many of the guys that were the
racquetball guys that died
also had no like fiscal literacy like
when you think about
fiscal like financial money literacy
across the board because you interact
so heavily across the board do you agree
with my assumptions that like
in general people's relationship with
money and even more so women
is just stunningly low absolutely i
think financial literacy
should be a prerequisite as much as you
need abc's
i agree right so because mindy shouldn't
shouldn't it be taught
shouldn't it be taught like hold up you
know they used to teach all that
they don't they basic and i don't even
wanna i don't like calling it financial
literacy
because i think that scares people right
it's just a scary word
it's a scary word right can we call it
can we call
it know what to do with your [ __ ]
money
you know i didn't even have the certain
other
classes i need to take and you know for
example
you know when i really went into
business and
um started up the ranks and really
owning p l as i said
i really need to be further educated and
i went to take the executive program at
harvard
right so why are we educating ourselves
about the business
and we're not spending as much time
educating ourselves about our financial
future
and you need to do both and i so agree
it needs to be
whatever you want to call um the
curricula
it needs to be a prerequisite
and that's a whole thing so you went you
actually took the initiative
to go and lifelong learner go and
understand it better
right you you took that but we've got to
help people
understand that they got to do it
earlier if this is
not calculus right this is not
complicated math
right you don't have to move from a
bouncy to a cash flow
you have i always faced it around having
that class
would have done more for most people
than calculus
but i also get married to a
mathematician so he gets a little upset
when i say
but i also think having that class with
contextual real life experiences
also helps a lot if you just read it
in isolation in a book would you really
have
gained the same value as having to live
and breathe
managing cash flow and liquidity and
investment and
all that and and i do think that
particularly for women
um we need to educate ourselves to have
the confidence
to make the investment decisions and
you know i'm sure you've brought it up
all the time we make 90
of the purchase decisions and just a
small percentage of the investment
decisions and
women need to be better advocates for
themselves and not abdicate their
responsibility
because it's so critical um
you know even if you're you're
partnering but
let's say you're just building your
what you need in your your career and
what you want in your life
setting those goals and having those
plans and understanding
um the risk that you're you know open to
taking
and what investment decisions at some
point do you need to start
thinking about that's education
so i mindy i couldn't agree and it's you
also talked about coming
out and and in in from college
you know i i too uh didn't get
married the first time so to speak i
walked away and
you have to own it yourself right and
that sends you and gary you talk often
about can i ask hope i'm sorry interrupt
you the fact that you and mindy have
this shared experience
this you know i love no really i love
you by the way
you too shell yeah this is just really
interesting to me because i think all
the good for me has been under
social studies and history
very simple question was that commonly
happening for strong women
in your generation like was that like
something that you know
you and your other a when i mean look
look at the three view of what ended up
happening
did you see that behavior happening from
was that happening quite a bit at that
time
or and or and
or and did a lot of people end up going
into those marriages and then get into
divorces or just live those unhappy
lives because they were the alpha
and that was what you were supposed to
do and that's supposed to you
had enough juice and a lot of women made
that decision because people were
getting married so much younger
also in that era just i'm very curious
from a social studies standpoint because
it might even help one listener today
going through yeah i mean
i think for me um you know i was adopted
and you know i was always told that i'd
been given this gift
so i took it very seriously so i
definitely rushed to get through
to prove something because i wanted to
be able
to then use that gift right so i was
very serious and i thought i had to be
on a certain timeline
and that's when i really had the
revelation that
it's not a timeline it has to be right
and you have to be passionate
you have to be purposeful you have to be
fulfilled
and that is ultimately what's going to
allow you to have impact
and you know i finally
got married um you know nine nine years
after that
um but i think sometimes first you need
the time
to get that self-awareness of what you
really need
yeah and i yeah and mindy i
completely agree but the difference for
me i was working in investment banking
and i was working crazy hours
and i was sort of told you can't do that
and i'm like i can't do that
like this
i can't live the crazy business life
and be married and have kids
um and i'm like are you kidding you mean
you want me barefoot in the kitchen
and it was it was definitely that that
you've got the wrong person here
um and i'm you know this i'm going to
make it for me
okay i'm not going to make it as misses
so
yeah myself as well totally i was going
for an mrs degree that was
for sure i never thought that i was
going to be the ceo of a company and
it was only until i
found my stride of who i was as a whole
person who i was in business
and who i wanted to be as a parent that
i was able to
you know become my best self not fall in
to it because i don't think i ever would
have ended up in the workplace
if i married um the person i was going
to marry
i would have been the supportive um
person
i think gary we're all three saying the
same thing it's also about self-reliance
ultimately we wanted to be the one
dictating the pathway we wanted to be
the one
owning it you know you know this whole
series to me is about getting everybody
else to stand up
capitalize on yourself and have the
confidence that you can do it let's give
you the tools
let's help you because that's ultimately
how change and equality happens
yeah and it goes back to what shelly
said it goes back to self-belief
right and confidence and
the ability to truly believe that you're
deserving and capable right and you have
to though
believe it first and i think that's
we're all saying something very similar
well i think confidence starts at the
age of five and so when gary was talking
about
you know the the learning in school you
know
even at a young age knowing your value
and your worth
that boys and girls are worth
the same and they bring different skills
to the table
and that's very powerful back to
capitalize on you
i just wanted to ask you mindy you know
from
compensation when you went for the big
job
and had to negotiate for yourself
um you know because you can have lawyers
and you can always but at the end of the
day you got to believe in you
and know what your value is where did
that come from how did you
do that first negotiate negotiation that
took you
place i i would say that that first
negotiation or the first range of
negotiations
were very uncomfortable and
i just kept saying to myself it's
okay to be uncomfortable but you need to
advocate for yourself
and i just remember there was one
negotiation
and at the last minute i almost
acquiesced to something and my husband
looked at me and said a man wouldn't do
that and was like
somebody slapped me in the face
and it's because i i wanted it
right and i stepped back and i said you
know every once in a while you need the
people that
can tell you the the truth and you have
to know your worth
right it's not just because you want
something what truly is your worth and
you need to
advocate for your worth so you know i've
always done
a lot of homework um and yes i've had
lawyers and yes i've had advisors but
i've done the homework on
what i think i'm worth and what i think
i can contribute to the business
um and if someone doesn't believe in
that then maybe i don't belong there
yeah and honestly for everybody who's
listening because
you know for example i don't know i
actually
my dad always makes fun of me because i
prefer to negotiate
in a manner that leaves a little bit
more on the other side of the table
than for myself it is my it is my state
it is what i'm most most comfortable
with
and i i've never associated that i
associate a lot of my things through the
years as i grew up
because my mom is my hero with my
feminine side
or my soft skills or when i even things
that are not
women versus men like empathy and
sympathy we've categorized those things
but i've always understood but i never
thought about my negotiation style
as that but i hear so much more about
know your worth
in you know in the female conversation
sector that i spend time in
but i i you i think everybody probably
understands this but i think it's
important it's like creative
you know we've talked about this mindy
and shelly in other business context
like creative
it's subjective one of my favorite
female juggernauts guild
tifford who you work with mindy like
even when she was at unilever
and by the way we said ww for like a lot
of people don't know that is
like the rebrand of weight watchers just
to give context for everybody listening
so you know when you go through rebrand
i always like to do that just so
everybody knows what's going on
um you know knowing your worth is
actually subjective
you know and could be fun you just
took the words out of my mouth it comes
in two
you have to look at where the business
is what you think you can contribute to
the business
and what do you think that impact is
going to be and
anyone who's looked at kind of i've been
running public companies so everything
is public
i build whatever that compensation is
betting on the impact i can make on the
company
and if i can make the impact i will be
compensated commensurately
and i've in particular
always chosen growth and transformation
so it's a different kind of 100
having empathy and understanding to the
audience
99.9 of the people here are definitely
not going to run a public company
and then 95 of the people here are going
to work in private environments where
they're not going to have very clean
data around the comps
but for example if you're a minority or
woman or if you're a man
white man everybody asking and putting
pressure on hr
or the owner or whatever around comps
you know
i come from family business land the
last two coaching ups i've done
have been for two people trying to
negotiate with a father
and one with a father one with a mother
owner where the kids are getting paid
four 400 000 to be losers in the
building
and they're driving the business at 120
and they're trying to figure out what to
do
that takes negotiating with sasha
vaynerchuk in that scenario
very different than negotiating with the
hr company at www.very different than if
you're joining
shelley's female private oh like there's
so many variables
i i think where i'm trying to go is
don't beat yourself
up if you've signed on a deal and you're
like
you know knowing if you if you got your
worth
can be very daunting i've noticed from
my perspective
but to your point mindy conceding
for something you do not want to concede
for you have to understand
saying no for yourself in that
negotiation makes no sense at least put
it on the table
let them say no a third time i i could
not agree and the other thing is
and i absolutely hear what you're saying
um
and again i think you do different
things at different points in your
career
and if you have made the decision right
and you've left
whatever it is uh because you can't
quantify
when you start and you are having an
impact
and you have quantitative measures
of your success on the business
don't be afraid to advocate for yourself
and
at some point go back
and have another conversation but you
know
oh sorry i hope you you said something
very important which was the
quantifiable piece
and that you also bet on the upside on
yourself
so you did your compensation negotiation
with equity and with cash but
where you put the big win was in what
you were gonna deliver
because you believe in you and you can
quantify
that performance success yes
and mindy mindy and shelly that's
exactly what's going to add
at some point there's a transition from
dollar
salary comp to equity and betting on
yourself
for the future and you have to have the
confidence
because that's where you build up really
long-term
capital especially if you help build the
business
and you have the belief in yourself your
team
and everybody around that make that bet
everybody can't at every
like point of their lifestyle but the
we're going to have conversations on
this show
about when you switch and when you step
on the gas with equity compensation
versus cash right and it really depends
on where you are in your financial
status
what risk you want to take um
you know if you don't have a home yet
you want to build investment for that
you're going to make
different decisions um on where that
balance is going to be
um so it's not a one size fits all
everybody's really individual
can i can i open up the forum for a
second i want all three of you to speak
to this
cynthia says this is not speaking to the
women who has
to who this is how she who has no time
to waste no money to waste and needs
exact
step by steps so for five
to ten minutes ramping here all three of
you please chime in
you know what do we say to cynthia who
leaves that comment right now on
facebook live of like
what's what is kind of some step-by-step
101s
for someone who's concerned about time
concerned about having to any or just
maybe just a tiny bit
of money working for her thoughts on
some scenarios you've seen and maybe
some practical tips of starting points
i'm going to start by cynthia i wrote a
piece
on the return on time i said i i got
taught on the return on investment from
a very young age because i've been in
finance my whole life
but nobody talks to women about the
return on time and i think it's
really really important you don't have a
lot of time and covitz probably
hopes hope back to time since they're
probably not going to go to your
linkedin though i recommend everyone
should because hope's on fire
and read it just some quick rapid like
are we talking about stuff that i get
passionate about which is like audit
your 7
p.m to 2 if you're not happy or you're
concerned you're anxious
but you're also watching entire seasons
of content on netflix
that's a debatable time because i talk
to people in really shitty situations
about time because i have a lot of
friends in shitty situations
and i have a large social footprint and
i'll go there for 25 minutes with one
person
because then i want the rep and i want
to bring value
even the ones that are in the most i
don't have time
when you really go there i understand
you have three kids one job single
parent you really go there
you get into this incredible debate of
one's need
for a little bit of escapism on a
tuesday night when they're fried
and their the opportunity to do
something with that hour and a half at
night
that may get you out of the hamster
wheel how do you think about that hope
from your perspective
well so it goes back to mindy was went
and took this
harvard class right now not everybody's
going to take that harvard class
there is plenty of material on
line to get a little bit of financial
education
and one of the things that i am
desperately hoping that this is going to
do as you
we roll out these guests is give you in
short snippets really good advice
on how to learn about investing
risk hr asking for more
and and so the little things you can do
every day
even if you take 15 minutes gary you
actually
joked with me about exercise about this
right you know you got to get your
head in the game and you know give 15
minutes extras how do we
take 15 minutes a day
i don't have time is the great excuse
of people that don't want to do it is
also
the sheer reality to a very small
percent of people
that have had incredible adversity in
their lives
they're both can be true but i speak
a lot of times to the 94 percent
because the six percent need a totally
different piece of content
let there be no confusion i don't have
time
is one of the easiest things to audit
when somebody's completely full of [ __ ]
what they're saying oftentimes is i'm
not motivated to do something i don't
enjoy
it goes back to self-awareness all of us
yeah really got hot on that
because you also have to think of of
this
as another form of self-care absolutely
financial security is self-care so i
think
assessing and having a deep knowledge of
where you are
at the moment and then setting a goal
that's definable and
when i say realistic you know i find
that what too many people do is they go
to set a goal and it's like right
something i'm gonna be beyonce and
create a billion dollar
makeup ring i think step goal steps
along the way
so you at least feel that you've
accomplished something
when you hit that first and it doesn't
have to be
big maybe it's just a change in behavior
um maybe it's just a a
a shift in uh focused
you know it could be any of those things
but i
am an obsessive list maker i always have
been
whether it's you know what do i see what
do i want in my next
you know career move um you know what do
i want in my life
and i find it very very helpful
because i have something i can really
refer to
when i can be distracted it keeps one
focused
on what really the priorities are and
you need to take that's where you need
to take the time and that's what i mean
by the form of self-care
and i think time is money and you need
to prioritize you need to focus because
you can't do it all
every day all the time you have one life
with five dimensions
you have your career you have your
family you have your community
you have your friends and the fifth is
yourself
and you can't forget about that bucket
and you know i have a no regret policy i
always look forward and i never want to
look back and say shoulda woulda caught
up
i think forward and act in the moment
every day is a new day
with choices time is choice how do you
want to spend your time
and be thoughtful and you can't do all
five dimensions all the time it's based
on your life stages and where you are so
pick and choose where your priorities
are where your focus are and then
allocate your time accordingly
so you never use excuses that you don't
have time
we all have you gotta make it where you
lay your self-awareness because mindy's
point is
so important it's such a please
everybody listen
when you make a goal that is what you
wish you were
versus what you are you are in deep
[ __ ] i always push people like i have i
mean i went through this with my sister
who's the best liz novello big shout out
finally as happy as i've ever seen her
why through a lot of
conversations with her older brother who
loves this [ __ ] and she has full access
to me
she had to go through a process of she's
not gonna she loves teaching
but she did it because it was the safest
she
she is so happy to and loves her kids
and is the best mother but she's not
going to be the mother that we had
who wanted more than breathing to stay
home and see
every second she's too alpha she had to
go back to
being 16 and selling baby clothes in a
baby outlet store
to remind herself that she loves selling
like her older brother
and now that she does real estate and
she does it
in balance with being a mother she's
shining
but she had to figure out and she was
driven by money let there be no like let
this be on the record
my sister is the my sister and dad are
far more and my grandmother that's the
lineage of the dna of that family
they are much more driven by money and
what i tried to explain to her is like
look
my passion led to something that did
money but i could have
very easily if the dna was different if
my passion was
art i might have done something that did
not make me as much money
because that because i'm in it for the
game you my sister
you are in it for the money take a step
back be self-aware and real estate
is a game that can this is back to the
question of like what's the step-by-step
step one what's the most likely [ __ ]
thing you can do that will give you
money
you you the human are you a worker bee
are you
an admin for a a-list superstar are you
good at buying stuff at garage sales and
thrift stores and flipping it should you
start a honey company
like you what are you best at to make
money
that's starting point one because you're
not saving and investing
becomes completely irrelevant if you
don't make enough to sustain a roof over
your head and eat
and have something left over and oh by
the way roof over your head and eat
doesn't mean bmw and prada bags
and all the [ __ ] [ __ ] all of you
are wasting money on which leaves you
with no money
because you're using those things as
oftentimes
band-aids for insecurity because you
want to look successful instead of being
successful
mindy your list when you said you're a
list taker i always say don't do a to-do
list
but have a to-be list of really you know
what
matters to you most sorry go ahead yeah
well actually the other thing
is have a not to-do list so i think the
prioritization
what i call ultimate discretion is
really
important especially in the beginning um
what is truly a need and then
when you want an indulgence have it be
purposeful
right and you know i've i've gone
through those
processes and you know i think that
um you know over the course of time um
compared to you know when i was my very
younger self
gary when i just wanted you know stuff i
was working i was making
i have i'm completely opposite now where
i'm very purposeful about those things
that are going to be important in my
life
and you know and that's what when i talk
to
younger women or younger people i said
the earlier you can start doing that um
the more fulfilled you will actually be
because the things you choose to do
are going to be that much more
meaningful to you well it's the wwe
uh eat healthy and purposely save the
last three points for something yummy
hope we got around exactly one round
so you know listen first of all this has
been great
and i believe mindy i couldn't agree
more about purpose
gary and i met on a non-profit board
it's all you know
it's not about buying for yourself it's
about being a giver
um so i think that's an unbelievable way
to close
and i also think it's about systems it's
about reaching out to
to other people the today's world of
social media we're all on it
we're all available reach out if you
need help if that
if you need help reach out ask for a
specific thing
find your sponsors um this is the
beginning
of a conversation that is so
unbelievably
important to me i think to all of us
here
it's about capitalizing on you and all
the toolkits we can give you
for success you know i like to say
you know what's the lesson to your
younger self
um and so mindy let's leave with
what's the lesson to your younger self
and gary
and shelly for the audience
yeah i would say be the master of
yourself
and it's kind of what is going to be
important to you
but determine that early and be very
strategic
thoughtful and purposeful about what you
decide to do
but it's also about belief that comes
from
education and knowledge and knowing when
is the right time to take a risk
michelle uh i'd say capitalize on you i
mean i think that it's it's be yourself
because everyone else has taken oscar
wilde says the best
garyvee i'm gonna go a little bit narrow
here i think that um
i grew up in a very immigrant household
where i'm gonna
talk to a different group of people here
where saving money was everything
like there was just was nothing else and
i've watched my dad navigate
that life and you know i had a lot of
those tendencies too
i think you know money in the bank
doesn't give the interest rates that
they used to and money in general
like so for a small group because i've
spent a lot of my energy here with the
people that
don't have it but like having thirteen
thousand dollars
you know twenty eight thousand dollars
and say like i i if i'm talking my
younger self
i did a really good job because i saved
they say they saved and i deployed very
high risks i thought i had a lot of
earning in front of me and i invested in
facebook twitter and tumblr and that
changed the course of my life that was
much better and then by the way my
famous passing on uber twice happened
because i overextended myself a little
bit on an apartment in new york city
and i valued having some cash a little
too much and passed on something that
was very intuitive to me which would
have come i mean that was a 500 million
dollar mistake
like there's no other way to say it real
life math back to the data
and so like thinking about my younger
self my advice
it's you know maybe have your cash
savings be even smaller than you think
you need it
and being thoughtful about where you
invested those dollars
so i think a little more offense because
the romance for me
off of that first generation immigration
and i think a lot of people
can think of their grandparents the way
i'm talking because those were the
people that first overvalued i think
there is some offense dna for younger me
who had a lot of there's a lot of people
right now who do have the ability
and believe in themselves to earn for a
long time and and if that's the case
you should be thoughtful about how you
invest and have a mix of
smart investing and probably some high
risk because cash and bank
surely gets really less sexy for
somebody that was like me and i over
valued it a lot of parts of my career so
that's that's the specific narrow one to
me
cash under the mattress doesn't go very
far either
yeah now that also still means like i
will go to the grave with a certain
number that's my personal number
of like true like armageddon and like
take the cash and run
um so i still have that but the bottom
line is we all need
we all need to learn we all need to
figure out what works for us
what kind of financial situation how
hungry are we
everybody's different i want to get
the tools out there so that we all can
be successful
so that we can build money and for those
that don't have
and don't have the time help them find
the resources
to get out of the hole to pay down debt
etc talk to you about debt talk to you
about interest rates
we're going to do that all on these
coming shows but the bottom line is
we truly believe that building and
capitalizing
on you can make a huge difference
in the future and that's why we're all
here mindy thank you
you know you are it was absolutely great
to my partners gary
so important and it's going to be
such a valuable asset to so many uh
and more now than ever
thank you and you were our first guest
you've just opened up
the door for so many more thank you
everyone thank you
thanks everyone for making a difference
bye everyone good luck
thank you thanks mindy great job
everyone